le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
au côté des
Réunionnais avoir une maison avec un
jardin est très agréable surtout ici
avec le climat que nous offre la Réunion
mais avoir un jardin réclame une bonne
forme physique pour un entretien
régulier et en prenant de l'âge ou après
un accident on devient moins vaillant
les forces nous abandonnent et les
jardins deviennent insalubres augmentant
les risques de maladie comme le Kunia
alors qui peut porter secours aux
personnes prises au piège par leurs
propres espaces verts on en parle
maintenant dans lien
[Musique]
social George Blanchard est retraité et
vit à Saint-Denis dans le quartier des
camélias il y a quelques années George a
malheureusement été victime d'une erreur
médicale une intervention chirurgicale
mal exécuté qui lui a quasiment retiré
l'usage de la main droite George ne peut
plus écrire et encore moin s'occupait de
son jardin envahi par la végétation il a
été victime du
chikungunia à cette même période c'est
par un ami que George a entendu parler
du glave groupe de lutte antictorielle
insertion et valorisation de
l'environnement suite à sa demande une
équipe est venue chez lui pour le
débarrasser de cette végétation
envahissante et aussi des objets
encombrants cela fait maintenant 5 ans
que George est soutenu par le glave un
service dont il aurait du mal à se
passer aujourd'hui
avec une broche dans le doigt et puis
des Ners qui sont abîmés il a fallu
quatre opérationsensite au CHD pour me
refaire la la main à peu près
correctement et donc je suis presque
invalide de la main droite et donc je
peux plus m'occuper de ma cours c'est
agréable de pouvoir faire appel à un
service comme ça lorsqu'on est en
difficulté qu'on est un petit peu
handicapé hein et c'est magnifique de
pouvoir compter sur des gars qui savent
vraiment bien travailler parce que les
gars sont super motivés ils sont pas là
pour rien faire ils sont là pour faire
un boulot qui pleuvent qui ventent il y
a pas de problème ben si vous étiez
passé hier matin vous auriez eu du mal à
traverser la cour parce que c'était une
véritable jungle avec des herbes routes
comme ça des arbres qui tombent un petit
peu de partout ben dans quelques jours
j'aurai une pelouse c'est pas magnifique
ça comme George d'autres personnes en
difficulté bénéfici des services du
glave toute l'année et sur toute l'île
ce dispositif initié par Dindar
présidente du conseil général profite
aussi bien aux bénéficiaires qu'aux
ouvriers du glève car ces travailleurs
courageux et volontaires sont en cuui
contrat unique
d'insertion la volonté du glve c'est
donc aussi d'aider des personnes sans
emploi à retrouver une vie active
professionnelle Moïse le chef d'équipe
était demandeur d'emploi jusqu'à ce
qu'il rentre au glèv à l'époque ben je
travaillais pas et ça fait qu' environ 6
ans 7 ans je travaillais pas et déposer
un C au GLV je travaille au GL depuis
et ma situation aujourd'hui je suis chef
d'quipe depuis
2009 moi responsabilité c'est que le
glève lu propose des formations en
paysasis
enagaz qu'il puisse s'en sortir avoir un
travail stable durable comme moi grâce
au GLV et à ses ouvriers George va enfin
pouvoir circuler dans sa cour et
retrouver une certaine qualité sanitaire
diminuant les risques de maladie ce
dispositif rencontre un réel succès
auprès de la population réunionnaise car
tous les acteurs de ce dispositif y
trouvent des solutions d'avenir que ce
soit les bénéficiaires ou les
intervenants l'amélioration des des
conditions d'habitat passe aussi par
l'amélioration de l'environnement de
l'habitat c'est ainsi que nous avons une
association qui s'appelle le glve dont
le rôle est d'intervenir dans les cours
des par particulier un revenu modeste
personnes âgées personnes portant
handicap en dessous d'un certain plafond
de revenu pour lutter contre les
maladies portées par les rats ou par les
moustiques donc nous aidons ces
personnes à nettoyer leur cours à les
débarrasser leurs déchets à éviter les
risques de chute de branches ou d'arbres
aussi chez eux et donc le glave qui en
même temps est un outil d'insertion
puisque 225 contrat uniqu d'ination
passent au Glèves travaill chez les
particuliers reçoivent une formation
nous avons donc grâce à cette action des
agents du glève une possibilité de
rendre beaucoup plus jolie beaucoup
plus fréquentable si je peux mettre
cette expression les cours des
particuliers qui sont touchés par des
phénomènes d'encombrant ou des des hutes
herbes que ces personnes âgées n'ont pas
l'occasion d'enlever aider des personnes
en difficulté tout en créant des
perspectives d'emploi c'est possible
grâce au GLV un double bénéfice que le
général au profit des réunionna une
initiative volontariste qui démontre une
fois de plus l'esprit de
solidarité le Conseil Général de la
Réunion vous a présenté lien social le
Conseil général au côté des
Réunionnais